[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
predators just don't sit around making
hats out of rib cages the conquered
space but that's not what's on the
horizon should I be worried Riley I
think you know what is on the ship the
ultimate predators welcome to night
school we need to grab four years of
high school into a semester I think his
mama breastfed him being they do respect
each in the conventional way just isn't
gonna get it done
why were you in ring with the square
root of 81 what you can get out my way
[ __ ]
[Music]
ready to get started I'm not playing
with you with the capital Belgian
waffles tell me something good do you
write songs or anything
I don't sing my own songs why I just
don't feel comfortable why wouldn't you
feel comfortable almost every single
person has told me they liked the way I
sounded but that they didn't like the
way I look I think you're beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
we have a deal I agree so many tracks on
the little time
hello Michael I have something you might
like to see
[Music]
do you know that I pray every night that
he would escape a bell did you do that
for
so I can kill him no one will players on
the radio we need to get experiments do
it again one more how many more
Galileo's do you want Roger there's only
room in this band for one hysterical
Queen Matt these words no one will play
free
you need to slow down friend if I don't
have time you're alleging fresh we're
all legends today we will do mean things
and we will do them in style
[Music]
[Music]
I take it we've heard the rumors wrinkle
for an efficient but he would rise to
dominance over the Wizarding World
you're asking me to help hunt him down
I can't move against Grendel fault
it has to be you did he lean it come on
[Music]
I was afraid I couldn't live up to these
expectations that might be a you don't
think you got your validation I got
I want to rewrite history don't pretend
this is about your father
is that my DNA we're going the Internet
[Music]
me for the troll
an ass-whooping
no leader
because I have no choice
I can't save my home and the people that
I love
you think your unreadable deed because
you're of two different worlds that is
exactly why you are worthy
[Music]